just before we get started with today's
video I do want to mention another
channel that I host called mega project
mega projects is a channel all about
mankind's greatest achievements where I
take a deep look at incredible buildings
project structures and more whether it's
the world's most impressive skyscrapers
the International Space Station or
Chernobyl sarcophagus I cover it all new
videos come out a couple of times a week
on mega projects so if you think it
could be for you please do head over and
subscribe there is a link in the
description below and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
unfortunately this is the situation that
Spanish people are living in these days
because of coronavirus
[Music]
a virus that is shaking the country in a
way that until just a few months ago
would have seemed to us to only belong
in an over-the-top Hollywood production
sadly at the time of making this video
more than 200,000 infections and more
than 20,000 deaths have been registered
in Spain and the worst part is there are
still several extremely tough weeks
ahead for Spain
these are the sort of figures that can
make your hair stand on end in order to
give you an idea during the final days
of March the coronaviruses increased
daily mortality in Spain by more than
70% that is deaths that occur for any
reason at all and obviously although it
is the worst part human tragedy is not
the only consequence of this crisis
since the second week of March all shops
except for supermarkets pharmacies and
some other essential establishments have
been closed for example all bars
restaurants clothing stores and shopping
centers are shut and of course retail
and hospitality businesses are not the
only ones affected companies of all
kinds including large industrial groups
have also been forced to stop their
day-to-day activities
this is something that has caused
hundreds of thousands of Spaniards to be
now put out of work on top of the stress
of confinements they have faced
dismissals or at best temporary layoffs
temporary layoffs already affect 1.5
million workers LPE
and yes many of these workers the vast
majority will probably get their jobs
back once this health crisis is finally
behind us but for many others this
collapse is short Amin losing their jobs
permanently
today there's a lot of uncertainty about
what may happen never before has the
switch that stops the country's economic
and social activity been flipped so
suddenly there just isn't any precedent
production activity plummets by 66%
because of uncertainty and declining
orders La Vanguardia so how did it come
to this not long ago we talked to you
here on visual politic about China's
handling of the whole thing we told you
how China publicly declared the epidemic
situation in the second half of January
within just a few days during the first
half of February many Asian countries
had already begun to put in place
serious measures to contain the possible
spread of the virus however in the West
well things were very different simply
but nothing was done until well into
March and the slow clumsy reaction from
countries such as Spain has had grave
consequences raincoats driving goggles
and shower caps doctors from Madrid on
the edge despair is beginning to be felt
by all health workers garbage bags
plastics and homemade material to fill
Hospital shortages promised resources
don't come out confidential in this
video we will tell you what Spain did to
become the country with the third
highest number of coronavirus cases in
the world
this is a story of politicians media
half-truths and many suspicions so let's
get into it
ah de la confianza al candidato Don
Pedro Sanchez Paris cos take on my
friend we started badly
2020 promise to be a good year for the
world's market seemed optimistic after
many swings threats and trade wars
unemployment in the United States was at
a historic low and for example in Spain
unemployment continued to reduce while
forecasts for economic growth were
fairly positive on January the 1st 2020
what no one could have imagined was that
a horrible year was about to begin
nevertheless in that same month of
January China already had hundreds of
confirmed cases of coronavirus in fact
it is suspected that real cases could
have already been well into the
thousands that is precisely why the
Chinese regime finally had to accept the
epidemic and take drastic measures such
as decreeing a blockade and an absolute
quarantine throughout who Bay Province
province of about 60 million people and
that's not all the rest of China was
idling people stopped being able to take
freely to the streets simply and plainly
put the world's largest factory had
stopped
a few days later the World Health
Organization considered this epidemic
and the resulting pandemic a global
health emergency January 31st 2020
coronavirus declared global health
emergency by World Health Organization
BBC and many of you will think but Simon
with all of these alarm signals it would
be normal that in countries like Spain
seeing the havoc such a situation could
cause there would have been some concern
and some preparation right well yes
you're not wrong that unfortunately no
none of that happens what's more the
opposite was true lo que tenemos que
tienen cuenta es que lo más peligroso
hora es el miedo mas que el propio
Vero's que como D go normal mental okay
a hakama sequoias is loss in tomas 9
horas inclusive que los demography
tenemos una situación Espania in the
carnival the pie is suppose up in
selfish and immature moment as you see
everything was fine in Spain the
Spaniards weren't going to get it away
as one of the leaders of the Vox party
the country's third largest political
organization said the Spanish antibodies
would defeat those damn Chinese viruses
yes he really said that out loud it's
quite incredible we should also note
that it seems that this perception was
also shared in some way by the Ministry
of Health both Minister Salvadorians the
head of the coordination center for
health alerts and emergencies Fernando
Simon both teams turn a blind eye to
what was happening much closer than
China in the lands of their
Mediterranean neighbor Italy
[Music]
look by the 29th of February Italy had
already surpassed a thousand known cases
of SARS coronavirus to infection
infections the belly a week later had
already exceeded 5000 despite this and
being - very similar countries with
close relations to each other the
Spanish government continued to do
virtually nothing in fact even when it
was known that the corona virus had
already reached Spanish soil no controls
were established at a horse nor were
trains buses or stations disinfected nor
were actions taken to purchase medical
equipments and materials just in case
nothing at all was done I mean come on
it's normal to do at least some of these
things when you know there's an unknown
virus out there a virus that's a
nightmare for your neighbor and that has
been able to stop the Chinese economy
dead in its tracks even at the most
critical moment the problem was not what
Spain didn't do but that their actions
made everything worse
[Music]
community Austin mom guess toggled on no
you need a lot of money first I feel a
little Toma Kalevala Liga Kasumi do I
know this might seem a bit controversial
but I'm sorry
we wouldn't be honest if we didn't say
it with all the data available
concerning March the 8th 2020 will go
down in history as the date that showed
that the government of Spain ignored the
coronavirus the SC for days and days and
despite the fact that the authorities
knew they've had to know since the virus
was moving freely through much of the
country
the Spanish government devoted itself to
downloading the risk with the apparent
intention that the news would not affect
the rallies that were to be held on
International Women's Day demonstrations
that in Spain are attenders in large
numbers and that have become a political
battle grounds are very important events
for the two parties that form the
current government psoe the Spanish
Socialist Workers Party and Potamus
and this is where we all have to ask
ourselves a question how laudable can a
cause be when it endangers public health
can a government looked the other way in
an epidemic in order to maintain its
political agenda that's not all
the same day rallies concerts sporting
events and many other events were held
throughout Spain we're literally
thousands and thousands of people were
exposed to the infection at the Vox
party rally in Madrid alone 9,000 people
were exposed to the virus in an enclosed
space on March the 8th to top it all off
a few days later it became known that
half of the party's hierarchy were
infected
yes that's right it was a marathon of
hugging shaking hands and kissing dozens
and dozens of people many of them who
were elderly - great ideas man and it's
no use pretending that at this time the
whole coronavirus thing was an unknown
threat not at all not only was there a
strong and clear international alert
from the WHI it was also known what was
happening in Italy meanwhile in Spain
itself more than 600 cases has already
been reported diagnosed and 17 people
had already died from corona virus the
Socialists led government of Pedro
Sanchez reacted late and clumsily the
country lacked essential equipment
ventilators protective clothing for
doctors and coronavirus tests are still
only just being sourced
Giles Tremlett the Guardians
correspondent based in Spain but at this
point the burning question is was the
Spanish government's lack of action a
miscalculation or something premeditated
well that's the question we're gonna try
to answer here so let's continue
[Music]
the turning point for the entire country
the Spanish government did not try too
hard to gloss over this one day exactly
one day was all it took for them to
change their discourse and get to work
on trying to slow the expansion of
coronavirus I mean put another way
until March the 8th the government was
encouraging people to take to the
streets and just a day later on March
the 9th suddenly suspiciously the
coronavirus problem became a mega
problem en los gatos indica no can you
happy or la adición there aren t me deaf
in Spanish press again they say produce
whole I every window Parata just one day
later incredible Madrid regional
government orders the shutdown of all
educational centers during the next two
weeks
Kadena ser and it's important to note
that the first measures were not
encouraged by the central government of
Spain but by the autonomous communities
like regional governments by the way up
to that point had done basically nothing
and indeed the truth is that at first
these measures lacked even a minimum
coordination between regional
governments and the national government
[Music]
for example the lack of restrictions
after educational activity was suspended
led many teachers and university
students to return to their home regions
with the consequent risk of spreading
the contagion across the country
something similar also happened when
President Pedro Sanchez announced the
state of alarm more than 24 hours before
implementing it who is a disaster but at
this point there is a question you might
be asking ok let Simon was this really
just to save a political rally in Madrid
if so why didn't regional governments
for example those controlled by
opposition parties do something to
protect their people well obviously
there's never only one reason and this
case was no difference many interests
were a play here
[Music]
it's clear Spain is a porous powerhouse
it's a Mediterranean country with lots
of Sun and kilometres and kilometres of
beaches as well as good food and cheap
alcohol it's basically a paradise for
millions of European tourists in fact in
2019 alone Spain received 84 million
tourists from the rest of the world 84
million tourists in a country of just
over 45 million so now you probably get
an idea of the importance that tourism
has in the Spanish economy we're talking
about more than 12% of its GDP and 2
million jobs so why are we telling you
about all this in a video about
coronavirus well basically because there
are a lot of clues that tourism has had
a lot to do with some politicians
especially regional politicians
preferring to look the other way
why risk stopping the engine that powers
the Spanish economy because of a simple
flu why cut your nose off despite your
face well that's what a lot of Spanish
politicians from the central government
to municipal governments even regional
ones must have thought no one wanted to
rock the boat but given where Spain is
now the question is what has been the
cost of not taking action will there be
political accountability for this whole
disaster totally damaged actually form a
distinct personality estancia the cuando
said - oh no sabemos no sorry
self-criticism say why
in all of the story there were only two
possibilities either act rapidly
accepting the severity of the problem
and enforce the measures from the
beginning to prevent the spread of the
virus all do nothing and find yourself
in an extremely dire situation like the
one facing several countries at the time
of posting this video unfortunately in
Spain the second option was chosen and
no it wasn't because they weren't warned
look at this 22 january china confirms
new coronavirus spreads from humans to
humans the new york times the night the
february corona virus deaths exceed SARS
fatalities in 2003 BBC 25th of February
coronavirus world must prepare for
pandemics as whm BBC well this was
published information so the Spanish
government must have had even more
expert advice especially given that
Fernando Simon the coordinator of the
health alerts and emergencies
Coordination Center is part of the
Committee of the European centers for
diseases the same institution that as
early as the second of March discouraged
mass event meetings
yes that's right the same man who said
he would tell his son to go to the 8th
of March rally in Madrid if he wanted to
was part of the European Centre that six
days earlier discouraged mass meetings
in order to prevent infection so is it
just me or does this all smell rather
fishy well that's not the end of it
within the various structures of the
state there were those who took the
risks seriously and of course the
government didn't take kindly to them
head of prevention of the National
Police who designed the protocol against
the corona virus is dismissed and mundo
we are talking about a manager who as
early as January warned his superiors of
the risk posed by corona virus to the
police force and designed a plan of
protective measures that did not sit
well with the upper spheres of power
but still there's more I'm sorry about
what's coming now but along with the
politicians the media didn't act wisely
in fact they delightedly joins that
campaign of ridiculing the importance of
coronavirus and even argued in some
programs that the common flu was more
dangerous than coronavirus itself some
tipo de Gripen nueva es verdad la mayor
parte de éstos infected assessed Andre
Cooper and Owen su casa como si fuera
una agrippa comme un perro de Cicco
parece que 16 de mess alarm is McKay
lost a toe
of course all this misinformation
together with the attitude of the
government not only caused inaction from
the state and local authorities but is
also likely the reason many people did
not take the threat seriously and
therefore didn't modify their behavior
in ways that may have helped slow the
virus and when it comes to not taking
action we can talk about medical
supplies such as rapid tests to diagnose
infections a test that now urgently
needs to be Poor's Yosemite Lozado a
complaint a post a merciless test
rápidos a low important said redundant
test fearless o morado history
importante es muy importante porque de
encantar canto a guarantee as a
Natalia's tenemos la compra Metis
resistant our polenta mill unidades
vamos a llegar antonio bus it was a case
of too little too late in a ridiculous
comedy of errors the Spanish government
taught hundreds of thousands of
defective tests from a shenzhen
companies that was not even certified by
the Chinese government China claims that
Spain purchased the failed tests from an
unlicensed manufacturer the Chinese
embassy in Spain states that the batch
of failed tests that Spain purchased was
obtained from a company that was not on
the Chinese government's list of
official vendors and confidency on so
you see just one disaster after another
[Music]
in a nutshell
this has been the course of events that
explains to a large extent what has led
Spain to become one of the largest
epicenters of coronavirus in the world I
think we can better understand the
differences between countries that have
managed you limit the damage of the
virus such as South Korea or Taiwan in
the case of Spain but now over to you do
you think that someone responsible for
such a dire performance should share the
responsibility and resign or leave their
posts well leave your answer in the
comments below and I really hope you
found that video interesting informative
if you did please do hit like also if
you'd like more from me please do check
out their megastructures channel that
I'm going to link to below and thank you
for watching and if you want to learn
more about politics and here even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
you